- So we're asked to
compare these two numbers
right over here and I just took a picture
from the Khan Academy exercise
but this isn't it, itself, so
I can't, I can't click on this,
but if you did click on
this on the exercise,
you'd get to choose
between one of these three,
but I'll just write it down.
So we're gonna compare 2.7 to
two and 17 hundredths,
so there's a bunch of
ways you could do this,
you could convert both
of them to mixed numbers.
So, for example, 2.7,
2.7, you could rewrite,
this is the same thing
as two and seven tenths,
two and seven tenths,
you could compare two and seven tenths to,
to this right over here, which is
two and 17 hundredths,
two and 17 hundredths.
So, they both have a two,
so you want to compare
the fraction part, so what's larger?
Seven tenths or 17 hundredths?
Well, if it doesn't jump out at you,
you could convert this to hundredths.
Seven tenths is the same
thing if you want to convert
it to hundredths, you can
multiply the denominator
by 10, which would make the 10 into 100,
and then you'd also have to
multiply the numerator by 10.
So two and 7 tenths is the same thing
as two and 70 hundredths.
And so 70 hundredths is for
sure bigger than 17 hundredths.
So, this number,
two and seven tenths, or two
and 70 hundredths, or 2.7,
is going to be greater than this number,
so it's going to be greater than,
we open the symbol to the larger number.
Another way that we could
have thought about this,
is we could have converted
both of them to decimals.
So we have 2.7, which we
can leave as a decimal.
2.7 but then two and 17
hundredths, we could write as 2.17.
This is 17 hundredths over here.
And there's a bunch of ways that you could
make this comparison, you could just say,
oh look, two and seven
tenths is the same thing
as two and 70 hundredths, over
here I have 70 hundredths,
over here I only have 17 hundredths,
so this is going to be larger.
This one's going to be
larger right over here.
Another way you could
have thought about it
is we'll just start in the ones place,
they both have two ones, so
that doesn't tell you much,
but as soon as you go to the tenths place,
this number as seven tenths and this one
only has one tenth, so
this number right over here
is going to be greater than that number.
Let's go to, let's do another example.
Which of the following are
less than two point zero three?
Or two and three hundredths?
Each big square represents one whole.
So one way we could do it, and this is
kind of the way that jumps out at me,
is let's, let's write
all of these as decimals.
So this one over here, we have one whole,
another whole, and then over
here I don't have a full whole,
let's see, I've taken a whole,
I've divided it into tenths,
and I have two tenths right over here,
so this number right over here
is equal to two and two tenths,
you see that, two, one, two, and then two
of the ten equal sections,
so two and two tenths,
which is the same thing as 2.2.
And if we wanted to compare it to 2.03,
well we just have to think about this,
well there's a, there's a bunch of ways
you could think about this,
you could view this as two point two zero,
which would mean this is
two and 20 hundredths,
and two and 20 hundredths
is for sure greater
than two and three hundredths.
So, this is not less than
2.03, this one over here
is greater than 2.03, so
I'm gonna rule that one out.
Another way you could
have thought about this
is this is two and two
tenths which is the same
thing as two and 20
hundredths, which this is
another way of representing that,
and you say, well this
one over, the number
you're comparing against is
two and three hundredths.
So 20 hundredths is greater
than three hundredths.
So once again this is not less than 2.03.
Here we have two and 12 hundredths,
and actually this is useful
because I already have
our original number represented as
two and three hundredths, so the whole
number part, the two, is the same,
so when you look at the fraction part,
12 hundredths is greater
than three hundredths,
so this one is also not less than 2.03.
Now what about 23 hundredths?
23 hundredths, we can write
like this, 23 hundredths,
or we could write it
and you might be tempted to say,
oh well hey, 23 hundredths,
that's bigger than
three hundredths, but
remember, we have two wholes
over here, we have two wholes,
we have no wholes over here, we have,
over here, one would think, but you have
nothing in the ones
place, over here you have
something in the ones place.
So if you look at the ones place,
you have two ones, you
have zero ones over here,
it doesn't matter how
many hundredths you have,
if you have less than a 100 hundredths,
and so, this one is for
sure less than 2.03.
This one is, this is
significantly less than even one.
So this one is the only, of the three,
that is less than 2.03.
Let's do one more of these.
Order the following values
from least to greatest.
And once again I took a picture
from the Khan Academy exercise,
so I'm not gonna be
able to drag 'em around,
if you're doing the exercise, you would be
able to drag them around, but I'm
just gonna, I'm just gonna
think about the numbers
and then write them in order.
So, I want to write them
all, let's write them all
in, as decimals, let's
write them all as decimals,
I guess is the easiest thing to do.
So here, this one's already
written as a decimal, 2.59.
24 tenths, 24 tenths, so
let's think about this.
That's 24 over 10.
Well, 24 over 10 is the same thing,
this is equal to 20 over
10, plus four over 10,
20 tenths, this is two
wholes right over here,
so this is the same thing
as two and four tenths,
two and four tenths, or,
the same thing as 2.4,
two and four tenths, now if
we wanna make a comparison
to two and 59 hundredths, we could throw
another zero right over here, and say OK,
we can view this as two and 40 hundredths.
So these are all different
ways of representing this,
some of you all might have
been able to go immediately,
hey look, 10 tenths is one,
20 tenths is two,
so 24 tenths is going to be
two and four tenths, or 2.4,
or 2.40, now let's try this number,
two and three tenths, represented as
2.3, if we want to think of it in terms of
if we want to think of it
in terms of hundredths,
you could say, well this
is the same thing as
two and 30 hundredths,
which you could also
represent as 2.30, and
the reason why I'm adding
the hundredth there is so we can
more easily make the comparison.
So you're comparing, you're comparing
two and 59 hundredths,
to two and 40 hundredths,
to two and 30 hundredths.
Well, they all have two in the ones place,
they all have two in the ones place.
So then we just have to
go to the tenths place.
And you see, this has the most tenths,
five tenths, this is the second most,
four tenths, and this
has the least tenths,
three tenths, so, ordering
from least to greatest:
the least is two and three tenths,
the least and three tenths,
which is equal to 2.3.
The next, the one larger,
next larger than that,
is going to be 24 tenths, 24
tenths, which is equal to 2.4,
and then the largest is 2.59.
And once again, this only, they all have
two in the ones place and
then you go to the tenths,
this has three tenths,
four tenths, five tenths.